my reality was feeling lonely while
tormented don't leave white countries I
sing to fans who don't see me or hear me
or cheer me on Little Mix singer
leigh-anne Pinnock fights back tears
over being the girl groups black member
nine years ago after joining Little Mix
I had the biggest awakening of my life
when we were filming wings who worked
with Frank Gatson he said to me you're
the black girl you have to work ten
times harder never in my life has
someone told me that I would need to
work harder because of my race later on
what Frank Garson said makes sense I
learned that the dream of being in the
biggest girl band in the world came of
its flaws and consequences consequences
such as knowing about the existing
underlying racism in the creative
industries in that emotional video
shared to her Instagram account Friday
the 28 year old British singer opens up
about her experience in the music
industry as a black woman you run by
voicing your opinion about the lack of
diversity within the industry is like
smashing your head against a brick wall
Liane captured the video in part quote
in the past I have mentioned some
personal experiences that were triggered
due to my race more than ever I felt
like it was time that I was completely
open and honest with you all because
finally the world is awake and people
want to listen help and understand my
reality is constantly feeling I have to
work ten times harder and longer too
much my taste in a group because my
talent alone isn't enough my reality is
wanting to see about artists who I know
is so talented but we'll never get
opportunities opportunities I account
look us to the industry they are not
marketable my reality is all the time I
felt invisible within my group part of
me is fully aware then my experience
would have been even harder to cope with
had I been got in Lee Anne is hoping the
awareness of racism and change will be a
movement not just a trend so all
continue to speak up on racism keep this
movement going
not long after Lee Ann's heartfelt post
fellow bandmate Jade Thirlwall
called out journalists for mislabelling
member
of the group in photos and real-life
make sure you're using an image of the
correct mixed-race member of the group
it's lazy journalism it's ignorant it's
rude Jayde's post and Leanne's candid
video come amid the civil unrest
happening around the globe surrounding
police brutality racism and the black
lives matter movement
aubriana is no matter how long you think
you have come racism exists
[Music]
you